herr bundeskanzler lieber olaf scholz
und
diejenigen die dazugehören herr schmidt
der zukünftige chef des bundes kann der
schon der chef des bundeskanzleramtes
ist der
noch nicht ernannte glaube ich
regierungssprecher
die staatsminister hier im kanzleramt
ich möchte sie ganz herzlich begrüßen
und das tue ich auch im namen all derer
die vorher diese funktion eingenommen
hatten ich konnte heute weil ich nicht
mehr mitglied des deutschen bundestages
bin olaf scholz noch nicht persönlich
gratulieren und möchte dass deshalb auf
diesem wege nachholen herzlichen
glückwunsch sehr geehrter bundeskanzler
lieber olaf scholz ich weiß aus eigenem
erleben dass es ein bewegender moment
ist in dieses amt gewählt zu werden sie
ahnen vielleicht dass es eine spannende
erfüllende aufgabe ist auch eine
fordernde aufgabe aber wenn man sie mit
freude an geht dann ist es vielleicht
auch eine der schönsten aufgaben die es
gibt für dieses land verantwortung zu
tragen ich wünsche ihnen von herzen
alles gute bei dieser arbeit und immer
eine glückliche hand für unser land und
diese wünsche erstrecken sich auch auf
das ganze team
corona bedingt sind wir heute in einem
sehr kleinen kreis hier versammelt als
ich damals von gerd schröder diese
aufgabe übernommen habe stand die
gesamte süd treppe voller
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die uns
jetzt zum teil auch zu hören und ich
darf ihnen sagen sie werden hier eine
mannschaft vorfinden die voller
leidenschaft voller engagement
arbeitet tag und wenn es sein muss auch
nachts die immer einsatzbereit ist
motiviert es gute ideen hat fachkundig
ist und das gilt für alle das gilt vom
innen schutz bis zu allen referenten
gruppenleitern und abteilungsleitern das
gilt von denen die in der küche arbeiten
bis zur registratur der poststelle und
in vielen vielen aufgaben die hier
ineinander greifen müssen wer sich
einmal ins kanzleramt
bewegt auch als mitarbeiter oder mit
weiteren der weiß was politik bedeutet
nämlich dass man morgens wenn man
aufsteht und hier zum dienst geht nicht
weiß was bis zum abend passiert ist dass
es immer dazu kommen kann dass man auch
auf ganz neue herausforderungen achten
muss ich weiß dass sie mit großer
motivation jetzt an die arbeit gehen und
deshalb
nehmen sie dieses haus in besitz und
arbeiten sie mit ihm zum besten unseres
landes das ist mein wunsch und ich
wünsche ihnen dabei alles gute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe frau merkel die wir frau
bundeskanzlerin ich möchte mich sehr für
ihre arbeit in den letzten 16 jahren
bedanken ich glaube dass man hier sehr
genau und sehr präzise sagen kann das
war eine große zeit in der sie kanzlerin
dieses landes waren und sie haben auch
großartiges bewegt wir haben viele viele
herausforderung zum welt nicht gehabt
bewältigen gehabt aber es waren immer
wieder auch große krisen die auf uns
zugekommen sind manche haben wir
gemeinsam durchgestanden in
unterschiedlichen funktionen aber auch
ich als mitglied des von ihnen geführten
kabinetts ich erinnere nur an die
finanzkrise 2008/2009 hier immer an die
großen herausforderungen die mit der
flucht migration 215 folgende verbunden
waren und natürlich jetzt wieder die
große ökonomische soziale
herausforderung die mit der krone
pandemie verbunden ist das hat
zusammengeschweißt und das waren nicht
nur diese ereignisse und zwischen uns
hat immer eine sehr vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit existiert das glaube ich
ist auch gut weil es zeigt dass wir eine
starke leistungsfähige demokratie sind
in der es einen großen konsens gibt
zwischen den verantwortlichen
demokratinnen und demokraten und es wird
auch in zukunft weiter unsere stärke aus
machen trotzdem sie haben dieses land
geprägt und auch diese regierung und
auch dieses haus und deshalb glaube ich
sagen zu können ist es schon irgendwie
was besonderes und ich will gerne
anknüpfen an die wie soll man das sagen
nordostdeutsche mentalität die da bisher
geherrscht so viel wird sich dann nicht
ändern
ich glaube dass wir alle hier
zurückgreifen können wie sie das schon
gesagt haben auf ganz großartige arbeit
die viele geleistet haben großartige
arbeit von den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern hier im haus und das ist
mir auch bisher schon sehr klar geworden
in den verantwortlichkeiten die ich
bisher hatte und sr freue ich mich auf
die enge zusammenarbeit danke sagen
möchte ich nicht nur ihnen sondern auch
all den anderen die hier an
verantwortlicher stelle
gesessen haben und gewirkt haben und die
mit ihnen hier versammelt sind auch da
ist viel an kooperation und zusammen in
den letzten jahren gewesen und daran
anzuknüpfen darauf aufzubauen das wird
mir jedenfalls eine große ehre sein ich
finde es ist etwas ganz besonderes
bundeskanzler dieser republik zu sein es
ist eine große herausforderung ich bin
sehr dankbar dass ich nun von den
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses landes
und vom deutschen bundestag den auftrag
gekriegt habe das zu machen dass wir so
lange so viele gemeinsame erfahrung
sammeln könnten das wird mir dabei
helfen schön dank mal nochmal für ihre
arbeit
[Applaus]
ja und noch mal an die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter denen heute nicht versammelt
sein können aber die und zuhören den
streams und den verschiedenen büros
gerichtet danke für das was sie bisher
geleistet haben danke für das was sie
leisten werden ich baue darauf und
setzte darauf und wir wissen dass der
übergang den wir jetzt hier miteinander
vollziehen einer ist mitten in einer
großen nicht abgeschlossenen krise das
setzt kontinuität und gemeinschaft
voraus und ich gehe davon aus dass uns
das auch gelingt frau merkel nicht
wissen dass wir wie corona pandemie nur
bekämpfen können in dem sich viele
impfen und lassen und viele
auffrischungsimpfungen holen indem wir
vorsichtig sind das gehört dazu und
deshalb ist es auch richtig dass unsere
zusammenkunft hier so etwas
begrenzt ist was die zahl der real
anwesenden betrifft das wir masken
tragen wenn wir am platz sitzen es ist
die grundlage dafür dass das gut
gelingen kann ich jedenfalls bin sehr
dankbar für das was wir bisher gemacht
haben ich freue mich auf die neue
aufgabe ich freue mich auf alle die hier
arbeiten und es war ein guter aufbruch
werden für unser land ich will
jedenfalls alles dafür tun schönen dank
[Applaus]